Speaker 1: Last week someone I think it was a
voicemail or maybe someone wrote to me and said,
David, do you think Herschel Walker understands
how the runoff works and the fact that because
no one got 50% in Georgia, now there's a runoff
just between him and Raphael Warnock. I said,
I have no clue what Herschel Walker does
or doesn't understand, but I did have a
curiosity as to what sorts of public statements
and appearances was Herschel Walker going to make
in this intermediate period between the November
election and the December six runoff? And it's
completely incoherent. So I can't tell you for
sure whether Herschel Walker understands the
runoff, but he seems very confused about a bunch
of other things. In this first clip, Herschel
Walker says We are the best country in the United
States. I don't know that he's wrong about that.
Speaker 4: Do you know where the greatest
country in the United States in the world?
Because we have the United States military.
Speaker 1: Yup. We are the best country in
the United States and the world because of the
military. Then Herschel Walker does seem to be
suffering from a touch of what we call the
Trump Delusion, where he believes only he
can save America. Now, remember, Trump said that
Trump said only he can help solve many issues. I
think in 2015, 2016, Trump was saying, only I can
fix health care. We never even got his health care
plan. Only he can fix trade. And of course, he
didn't. And this seems to now be I don't know that
a requirement, but it certainly seems beneficial.
And to a degree it makes sense if you are
completely unqualified, hypocritical, unethical,
clueless and have no business in elected office,
you first have to convince yourself that you have
some business running. And in order to do that,
you probably tell yourselves lies like the
entire country is depending on this. And
that's exactly what he said to Larry Kudlow.
Speaker 4: I love the United States of America.
If I do not win that seat, we may not recognize
America as soon as they get back in control
because they seem not to like America. I want
America to be great. I want every kid in America
to have that American dream. Well, I can tell
you right now, if I don't win, I see no other
America. We ever have that American dream again.
Speaker 1: Yep. The entire American dream depends
on Herschel Walker, who's completely unqualified
and doesn't know up from down when it comes to
policy if he doesn't win. No kid in America
will ever achieve the American dream. That's a
sickness that is unique to the Republican Party.
You hear? You know, we talk about in many areas,
Democrats and Republicans are more or less the
same. And in other areas, they're very different.
This particular sort of God complex I don't see
on the left, I just don't see it. Even Barack
Obama, who knew he would be the first black
president? Half black. Of course, as we know,
even when he was asked about like, is.
Speaker 3: This.
Speaker 1: The most important thing, a black
person, whatever, there was a statement and
he said, well, listen, it's important, but think
about all of these other people. And he listed a
half dozen other people. This is a unique type of
delusion that you see on the right. Here is a oh,
here's Walker again, continuing to talk about
pronouns. And I really don't know that he knows
what pronouns are. I'm increasingly suspicious.
Speaker 4: But yet they bring in pronouns
that bring him pronouns and our
military. Right. So his pronoun
going to be former senator pronoun? Yes, it.
Speaker 1: Born this season yet? Rafael Warnock's
pronouns are going to be former senator. I
have it on good authority that if he wins,
Herschel Walker is going to launch a brutal
assault on prepositional phrases the likes
of which you have never even dreamed about.
Ted Cruz appeared alongside Herschel Walker
on Fox News and he just kind of nodded along
as Herschel Walker made no sense and visibly
struggled to use language to communicate.
Speaker 4: He's a hypocrite. And being a pastor,
I say this How can he keep the Almighty
O to the Almighty God and he keep it
for them? He kept for neither nobody. So
that proves the type of man he really is.
Speaker 1: All right. So, Cruz,
you're the leader. Ted Cruz has had
it's like a bobblehead doll blocker here.
Speaker 3: You're going to have to open
up some holes for Herschel Walker. Yeah.
Speaker 1: It's all just so, so, so great,
guys. And then here is sort of like
the cherry on top. Laura Ingraham on
Fox News interviewing Herschel Walker.
Speaker 4: They said we are in overtime.
Unidentified: In overtime that it we got a little
hey I.
Speaker 4: Built for this.
Speaker 3: Georgia is the third
state that could decide the fate of
the Senate. And with its second runoff, it turns.
Speaker 1: Out it won't. Right? Because Democrats
held the Senate. Since this interview aired.
Speaker 3: Just as many years, it's also the
second most expensive race this
cycle, totaling $262 million.
Speaker 1: By the way, one of the things
these right wingers are able to do is just
turn a fact into like a criticism of
Democrats. This is a super expensive
race and they act as if that's proof that you
should vote for Walker in some way. So, yeah,
the race was expensive and Walker is incompetent.
Speaker 3: Joining us now is Republican Herschel
Walker, who is really good. And over time,
I have to say Georgia Senate candidate. Ah,
so great to see you tonight as always. How
are you feeling right now after this wild
week where we have so many races across the
country still undecided and you are heading
to this runoff?
Speaker 4:
Well, I feel pretty good. The reason why I'm still
fighting for the people of Georgia, you know,
that's when I got into this race about it was
about the people of Georgia that they were not
represented well in Washington. We have a senator
that seemed to be represented in Washington are
California and New York, not Georgia. In Georgia
need a champion. And I'm that champion because I'm
going to get into Washington and let the people
voices be heard and let the people know that
they have that champion there. Because, Senator,
one has not done it since he went to Washington.
Listen. Than years, people say, well, yeah.
Speaker 3: Herschel McConnell. Mitch McConnell
is turning to Governor camp for help in this race.
Politico is reporting that camp is loaning his get
out the vote machine to the Senate's GOP voter
turnout efforts, giving the party entree to.
Speaker 1: I'm curious what he'll say about this.
Speaker 3: Political team that is increasingly
viewed as one of the GOP's most formidable state
operations. And at the same time, we understand
the Democrats have already invested $7 million in
get out the vote efforts, which sounds like ballot
harvesting to me, which is legal in your state.
Speaker 1: Listen, they're spending money on
this election. There's got to
be something illegal there.
Speaker 3: What's the way to win this race
now with the remaining weeks that you have?
Speaker 4: Well, you know, it's
such a short time. And, you know,
the Democrat is trying to buy this seat to.
Speaker 1: Triangulate that money spent by
the Democrats is to buy the seat, whereas all the
money spent on the behalf of Herschel Walker is
just democracy or whatever the case may be. This
is a crucial race. It's now about 51 rather than
50 and making Joe Manchin irrelevant. So we are
going to be following that race closely. We are
going to be activating around that race.
We'll have more information for you soon.